des troupeaux pris pour cible de
nouvelles brebis ont été attaqués et
tués à mélisey dans l'yonne l'éleveur
qui est aussi le maire de cette commune
du tonnerrois a découvert ces animaux
hier pour lui il ne fait aucun doute que
le loup a encore frappé en l'écoutant on
a regardé avec les garder c'est il ya
des crocs énorme
et puis on a une cale à la trachée
broyer bah dis donc il a dû serrer fort
vu la grosseur des pâtes qu'on a
retrouvée dans le pré vu la grosseur des
croquis et est marqué sur le sur le coup
on est on suppose quand même que celle
où parce que c'était énorme
ça fait six mois six mois il a il a
construit son territoire dans le secteur
des pythons mais à droite à gauche puis
revient de temps en temps en le problème
qui a cédé au printemps
est ce qu'on va faire des moutons
printemps si on peut parler lâcher